major breaking news over the last 24
hours including 17 17 guilty counts for
the Trump organization in this massive
New York investigation that has been
going on for some time it involves
Trump's former CFO Al and weisselberg
this is a major story which has
instantly triggered the failed former
president but let's not get ahead of
ourselves let's go through it piece by
piece New York Times reports Trump
organization found guilty in tax fraud
scheme the former president's company
had been accused of providing
off-the-book benefits to Executives the
testimony of its former Chief Financial
Officer proved crucial to the case so
what exactly is it that happened
the conviction on all 17 counts after
more than a day of jury deliberations in
state supreme court in Manhattan stem
from the company's practice of Doling
out off the books perks to Executives
they receive luxury apartments leased
mercedes-benzes extra cash at Christmas
Even free cable television and they paid
taxes on none of it this is a very
simple thing my accountant has talked to
me about how this works many many times
before
imagine that you have something very
simple okay you have your business
leases you a car a beautiful vehicle
drives you around four wheels tires the
entire thing can go forwards and
backwards okay gets you where you need
to go let's imagine the leases to pick a
number 500 a month which is six thousand
dollars for the year the business pays
the six thousand dollars it's a business
expense for the business six thousand
dollars in lease costs but if that
vehicle is only available to one person
really it's considered a fringe benefit
and that six thousand dollars should be
added to that individual's W-2
and that you pay taxes on it you don't
get the six grand you get a lease worth
six thousand dollars and then you pay
taxes on that six thousand dollars now
six thousand dollars is very quaint
because what we're talking about here is
luxury apartments I believe at issue
also was educational expenses for family
members of Alan weisselberg and
potentially others so you're talking
about a lot more money this is classic
stuff and the idea that this is obscure
or in some way Petty is absurd any
reasonable account will tell you you
know this is the way that it has to go
um going back to the article the
Manhattan District Attorney's office
which prosecuted the case previously
obtained a guilty plea from the
architect of the scheme Alan weisselberg
the longtime CFO and weisselberg
ultimately testified as the prosecution
star witness but never implicated Trump
very important prosecutors didn't charge
Trump but they invoked him throughout
the trial telling jurors he paid for
some of the stuff and even approved a
basic a crucial aspect of the scheme
importantly the verdict carries limited
Financial repercussions and will not
directly threaten to imperil Trump's
company but the conviction and the
prosecution's explosive claim and
closing arguments that Trump was quote
explicitly sanctioning tax fraud could
reverberate during his nascent 2024
presidential campaign and provide fodder
for political opponents so 17 guilty
verdicts but not going to imperil
Trump's company here's the report from
MSNBC as the news came in Long scheme
that would basically try to compensate
top Executives or help these Executives
what is it
guilty on all accounts we have a verdict
it is guilty on all 17 counts uh just in
moments ago after about 10 hours of
deliberations and you're right Hallie
this is a case against the Trump
Corporation two entities of the Trump
Corporation there were no named
individuals former president Donald
Trump was not named but certainly this
this is his family company this is his
livelihood this is his business this is
his reputation this is all things Donald
Trump accept him being named as a
defendant in this case you might say so
that is from MSNBC CNN also had the
report of the verdict what do you know
well Victor that's right the jury just
returned to verdict guilty guilty on all
counts against both Trump corporations
entities that means that the jury after
two days of deliberations and four notes
today came back with this decisive
verdict unanimous guilty on all counts
now remember the two Trump organization
entities were accused of being involved
in a 15-year tax fraud scheme where they
gave their Executives certain Executives
off the books compensation that was
Corporate Apartments that were rent free
that was company cars that was private
school tuition for Alan Weisberg the
chief financial officers grandchildren
the jury finding the companies were
guilty on that now Donald Trump former
president was not charged in this case
but its name did come out at the trial
including on closing statements one of
the prosecutors saying that he believed
that Donald Trump had sanctioned some of
this tax fraud of course he did and as
Michael Cohen has spoken about many
times uh Trump knew exactly what was
going on 17 guilty verdicts let's now go
to Don Donald Trump's reaction good
habits have to be sustainable in order
to become habits it has to be something
you'll actually do and when it comes to
nutrition some people have hours to plan
out every meal their exact vitamin
intake I'm not doing any of that I don't
have the time here's what's sustainable
for me I start my day with just a single
scoop of ag-1 from athletic greens it
gives me the entire day's worth of the
75 high quality vitamins minerals and
probiotics I want from whole food
sources it's just simple it's just one
scoop of ag1 I get all the nutrients I
want I don't have to do any math use my
protractor my TI-83 or take a bunch of
different capsules and pills it's not
some kind of wacky supplement making a
bunch of crazy claims you know I would
not promote something like that ag1 is
just a simple product it does what it
says it does it gives you the daily
nutrients and vitamins you likely want
vitamin A C E magnesium zinc potassium
in one simple scoop you keep your body
nourished you'll also get a free year
supply of vitamin D which I take in the
winter plus five free travel packs at
athleticgreens.com Pacman the link is
down below